at this altitude this episode is brought
to you by 4 Sigma Dec founded by the
genius Finn's who lit the internet on
fire and you may have heard of their
mushroom coffee which features chaga and
lion's mane which has taken Silicon
Valley by storm I use it pretty much
every day either that or the chaga which
is decaf as a separate version and I use
both of these primarily for focus and
productivity they just get you going
light you up like a Christmas tree so
definitely check it out people are
always asking me what I use for
cognitive enhancement and for right now
this is the answer I try to force this
on all of my houseguests it is a hell of
a thing if I have employees or people
come over who aren't working on projects
with me I always try to feed it to them
because I'm going to get the limitless
effect gets a lot more out of them the
first time I mentioned this product and
for sig Matic on the podcast their
products sold out in less than a week so
you may want to check them out soon if
you're listening to this and the coffee
tastes like coffee
it takes just seconds to prepare with
hot water and oddly enough only includes
40 milligrams of caffeine so it has less
than half of what you would get in a
regular cup of coffee I don't get any
jitters acid reflux or any stomach burn
any of that it's very unusual and very
very cool so if you don't like caffeine
they also offer very strong but caffeine
free mushroom elixirs which I will
sometimes have in the evening I find
chaga specifically to be very very
grounding and earthy so that is another
option and I have a cupboard full of
their products at the moment which is
right around the corner of my kitchen
you can try something right now by going
to four sigma tech calm forward slash
Tim that's for sig Matic fo you are SI
GM a tea ice
calm forward-slash Tim and use the code
tim TI m to get 20% off of your first
order and they're not that expensive
anyway if you are in the experimental
mindset I do not think you'll be
disappointed to try my hello boys and
girls ladies and germs this is Tim
Ferriss welcome to another episode of
the Tim Ferriss show where it is usually
my job to sit down with world-class
performers of all different types
startup founders investors chess
champions Olympic athletes you name it
to tease out that habits that you can
apply in your own lives this episode
however is an experiment and part of a
short-form series that I'm doing simply
called books I've loved I've invited
some amazing past guests close friends
and new faces to share their favorite
books describe their favorite books the
books that have influenced them changed
them transform them for the better and I
hope you pick up one or two new mentors
in the form of books from this new
series and apply the lessons in your own
life I had a lot of fun putting this
together inviting these people to
participate and have learned so so much
myself I hope that is also the case for
you please enjoy well hello boys and
girls my name is Steve Jurvetson and I
am an early-stage venture capitalist
with a focus on founder led mission
driven companies at the cutting edge of
disruptive technology and new industry
formation
I led founding investments in five
companies on public and successful IPOs
and several others that were required
for a total of over a hundred billion
dollars in value creation I currently
serve on the boards of Tesla SpaceX in
d-wave which is a quantum computing
company before founding future ventures
the venture firm on that now and dfj
before it I was an RD engineer at
Hewlett Packard and worked in product
marketing and Apple and next and
management consulting with Bain &
Company and I was originally trained in
Electrical Engineering going all the way
through to a PhD but not completing it
so today I'll present three books the
most gifted book by me the one had given
to most people the most influential book
on me and then the most important book
for all in my humble opinion so let me
start with the gift book I've gifted
more than any other it is scientist in
the crib by alison gopnik she's a
professor of developmental psychology at
Berkeley and I basically give this book
to any geek friend of mine
about to have their first child because
it had such a wonderful influence on me
it is not a parenting book but it
nevertheless it Kindles in awe and
awareness for the marvels of their minds
babies minds especially in the pre
verbal years when it might otherwise be
difficult to connect some practical
experiments come out of this once you
understand that babies signal their
interest in things by where there is
focus their gaze this is the fundamental
research tool used by cop Nick and
others in their practitioner of their
art and that that focus shifts over time
as the brain develops and they face new
developmental milestones so for example
at Birth much of the vision systems
bootstrapping
and this is everything from the color
space to distance vision and initially
edge detection meaning for seeing the
edge of an object and its
three-dimensional distance if you will
this is how you sort of can make a
difference we can foreground and
background and make sense of the world
in three dimensions so I would notice
that when I could take advantage of this
basically even at the hospital when my
son was one day old I noticed that when
I pushed his bassinet with the sleeping
baby through a hospital hallway his eyes
would just pop open whenever I turned a
certain corner it was like clockwork and
so I looked up and I saw a right angle
in a long bright line of fluorescent
lights so ran down the hallway and made
a right turn and sure enough when I
closed my own eyes and looked up I could
see that sharp edge of light through my
own closed eyelids AHA this was like
food for the baby's developing brain it
made him happy to open his eyes to this
visual treat that was the thing he was
cognitively working on most at that time
and it made it great for me to show this
to others I could get him to open his
eyes for visitors by repeating this
trick for them and again it'd be sort of
a joyful way to wake a sleeping baby
then later when my daughter was first
learning to speak but had not mastered
all the sounds I noticed her gaze would
flip around to my mouth whenever made a
butt butt or a pass out a B or a P but
imagine learning those for the first
time it is a very subtle difference in
mouth position and how else could we
learn this but to watch someone else so
I then had many days of enjoyable
phoneme practice as I called it with her
as she came to master the elements of
speech I think science is McRib is
fascinating not just for the life in the
crib before it tells us about scientists
as well it is an inspiration for adult
life from what I can see the best
scientists and engineers nurture a
childlike mind they are playful open
minded and unrestrained by the
voice of reason collective cynicism or
fear of failure Isaac Newton in Richard
Fineman are famous examples of this I've
come to celebrate the childlike mind as
I call it and here is one of Alison
Gopnik skee conclusions from her book
and this is a direct quote babies are
just plain smarter than we are at least
if being smart means being able to learn
something new they think draw
conclusions make predictions look for
explanations and even do experiments in
fact scientists are successful precisely
because they emulate what children do
naturally at a recent talk I heard that
the long enough foundation Alison Gopnik
went further to say the three and four
year olds do causal inference better
than the best scientists we know just
kind of fascinating so what is this well
much of the humans brain power derives
from its massive synaptic
interconnectivity the connection between
neurons Jeffery west from the Santa Fe
Institute observed that a cross-species
synapses per neuron meaning how many
connections each neuron has to his
neighbors it fans out with a power-law
with brain mass in other words this is
something that is endemic to larger and
larger brains in the evolutionary
landscape in an age of 2 to 3 years old
so when your babies now become a young
child 2 to 3 years old they hit their
peak with 10 times as many synapses as
we have as adults literally 10 times as
many interconnects as we do and twice
the total energy burn of an adult brain
well it's all downhill from there the
UCSF M memory in the aging Center has
tracked cognitive ability of age for
example they have a delayed free recall
test quite simply to read 16 words and
after some time has passed you're tested
how many you can recall unprompted from
the teen years to our mid 30s we all
remember about 12 of the 16 words it's
pretty much a flat line on the graph but
then about in our mid-30s the line
shifts to a completely different
straight line that's declining over time
until end of life but it's at the same
slope in other words the pace of
cognitive decline is the same in our 40s
as in our 60s as our 70s and in our 80s
we just notice more accumulated decline
as we get older especially when we cross
the threshold of forgetting most of what
we try to remember in our late 70s to
early 80's per that graph but we can
affect this progression that's a graph
looking in the past
professor Murch initial UCSF has also
found that neural plasticity does not
disappear in adults it just requires a
mental exercise the old adage of use it
or lose it so the bottom line from this
in terms of a
adults sort of learning and
recommendations is that we should
embrace lifelong learning we should do
something new physical exercises
repetitive mental exercise is eclectic
and that princess to the next book an
eclectic romp by Kevin Kelly the
founding editor of Wired magazine and
it's book called out of control now this
is the most influential book on me and
it has guided many of my investment
theses over the last 20 years in
technology development
it basically is a book that covers the
dawn of the age of biology as the next
phase of major technology vectors coming
out of an age of physics if you will and
these biological metaphors are ripe
throughout information technology in
Kevin Kelley very expertly explores the
integration of these domains so the
interesting thing is that this book was
written in 1995 and it may have been 20
years ahead of its time it was recently
translated into Mandarin and it is
currently a best-seller in China as if
it were written today as if this was
something that just went to a time
capsule and now is really when it's
hitting powerfully on our shores so as
an introduction to the power of
evolutionary algorithms and information
networks inspired by biology Kevin
Kelley basically explores what
fundamentally are the underlying
principles of complexity theory at the
Santa Fe Institute the properties of
emergence self-organization what some
would call the wisdom of crowds when you
have many people behaving as a team and
outperforming as they would perform as
just individuals or that of a hive mind
or you know how the social insects do
what they do it motivates the benefits
of exploring biomimicry basically
learning from biology especially in our
information systems like neural networks
what we now call deep learning or
machine learning which are basically
recapitulating in silicon the
evolutionary and fetal development of
our cognition so when you train these
artificial neural networks these layers
are basically forming much like they do
in a fetus going back to the house and
Gopnik it basically starts with edge
detection then symmetry subsystems
eventually builds up to facial
recognition and then identifying
people's faces these are different
layers and the neural nets that form in
that consecutive order just like our
infants so basically if you look at
where Moore's laws taking us and what
computation is taking us we're now at
the cutting edge of computational
capture in biology we're actively
re-engineering the information systems
of biology and creating synthetic
microbes whose DNA is manufactured from
Barrett compute
code and an organic chemistry printer
and the challenge we face in many of
these synthetic biology domains is you
know question of what to build so far
we've largely just copied large tracts
of code from nature but the question
then spans across all the complex
systems who might want to build from
cities to designer microbes to computer
intelligence as all these systems
transcend human comprehension basically
as we try to design more than we can
comprehend more than we can understand
we will shift from traditional
engineering to evolutionary algorithms
an iterative learning algorithms like
deep learning and machine learning and
as we shift this engineering to the
training of these iterative algorithms
the locus of learning shifts from
artifacts themselves to the process that
created them
there is no mathematical shortcut to get
through the decomposition of a neural
network or to reverse-engineer it or a
genetic program there's no way to
reverse evolve with the same ease we can
reverse-engineer the artifacts of
purposeful design the beauty of these
compounding iterative algorithms by this
I mean evolution fractals organic growth
art that derives from their
irreducibility their computational
irreducibility no mathematical shortcuts
and it empowers us to design complex
systems that exceed human understanding
in short we are reengineering
Engineering itself it starts to look
more like parenting than programming and
that brings us to the age of spiritual
machines by Ray Kurzweil the inventor
and futurist I think this might be the
most important book and even maybe more
shockingly I would say there is a single
graph in the book that itself makes this
book the most important book one could
read and obviously therefore it's simply
this one graph the graph of the 120 year
version of Moore's Law so let me explain
what I mean by this
and also just mention perhaps and
starting that it's really just the first
few chapters of this book I'd recommend
not the entire book that looks into the
distant distant future like the next
hundred years but really just the
background the historical section and
then let yourself make your own
conclusions and basically this book
introduces the best abstraction of
Moore's law that I seen out there one
that is understandable meaningful even
cosmological and has predictive power so
it is I think essential for tech
futurism predicting where we're heading
as well as business planning as most
businesses become technology businesses
understanding how to predict our future
becomes all the more important so the
popular perception of Moore's law that
again Gordon Moore from Intel who
created
computer power getting better and better
basically is this sense the computer
chips are compounding in their
complexity at a near-constant unit cost
so it's a sort of bang for the buck kind
of representation and but this is just
one of the many abstractions in Moore's
Law you know people have all kinds of
different ways of defining it you get
different answers from different people
but it relates to the compounding
transistor density and true dimensions
other renditions of this Moore's Law
just relate to speed like how many mega
Hertz or Giga Hertz do we have on our
chips that was some of the early days
when people didn't really know what they
were talking about and it makes sense
that you know as you miniaturize a chip
the distance traveled by any given
signal is less so everything runs faster
where are some people refer to
computational power which is basically
speed times density because both
benefits accrue as you measure eyes so
for a long time this was thought to be
very specific to Intel yeah but unless
you work for a chip company like Intel
and you unless you focus on fab yield
optimization you don't really care about
transistor counts nobody goes out and
buys a million transistors or give me a
billion transistors that makes no sense
right integrated circuit customers don't
buy that they are basically consumers of
technology and they buy computational
speed and data storage that's what we
care about and quite simply
Ray Kurzweil in his book plots the
calculations per second so computational
power
how many calx per second that you could
buy for a constant dollar so again
adjusting for inflation over a long
period of time and recursion was
abstraction of Moore's law shows that
computational power has followed a
smooth exponential curve for over a
hundred and twenty years basically since
the beginning of data on any kind of
computer is a straight line on semi-log
paper men there was years along the
x-axis and a a logarithmic scale of
computational power per dollar on the
y-axis and it shows a geometric
compounding curve of progress when
recast in these terms
Moore's Law is no longer transistor
centric in this abstraction allows for
longer term analysis similar is not
specific to Intel what Moore Gordon
Moore the person observed in the belly
of the early integrated circuit industry
was a derivative metric a refracted
signal from a longer term trend a trend
that begs various philosophical
questions and predicts mind-bending
features through five paradigm shifts
such as electro mechanical calculators
and vacuum tube computers the
computational power that a dollar buys
has doubled every 18 months for 120
years every dot on this curve is
basically on the frontier of
computational price perform
the day 1 machine was used in the 1890
census 1 craft and Nazi enigma cipher in
World War 2 if you saw them with the
imitation game one predicted
Eisenhower's win in the 56 presidential
election I have been updating this graph
since basically the time of the book
which was a while a while back and had
basically found over the last 10 to 20
years that I've added to this curve that
the latest CPUs and specifically nvidia
gpus the graphic chips carry out this
precise same curve of progress to the
present day and that sort of extending
Kurzweil analysis I think 20 years past
when he stopped the curve so every dot
every machine on this curve represents a
human drama prior to Moore's law which
was first formulated in 1965 none of the
people on the curve even knew they were
on a predictive curve right it wasn't
until Gordon Moore basically came up
with Moore's law that we would have
thought to even plot such a thing and
every dot represents an attempt to build
the best computer with the best tools of
the day of course we also used these
computers to make better design software
better manufacturing control algorithms
and so progress continues but notice
that the pace of innovation a straight
line imagine that 420 years is exogenous
to the economy think about how long this
is held true the Great Depression world
war one world war two in various
recessions have not introduced any
meaningful change in the long-term
trajectory Moore's law certainly the
adoption rates revenue profits and
economic fates of each of the underlying
computer companies behind the various
dots may go through wild oscillations
but yet the long-term trends emerges
nevertheless as one technology such as
the CMOS transistor the current
technology to short follows an elongated
s-curve of slow progress turning the
she'll development upper a progress
during a rapid adoption phase and then
slower growth from market saturation
over time but a more generalized
capabilities such as computation which
isn't I'd the one thing storage more
generally bandwidth more generally they
tend to follow a pure exponential
bridging across a variety of different
technologies in their cascade of s
curves hmm well in the modern era of
accelerating change in the tech industry
it's hard to even find a five-year trend
with any predictive value you get let
alone a trend that spans centuries I
would go further than assert as I did
that this is the most important graph
ever conceived so why why do we think
it's the most important graph in history
well a large and growing set of
industries depend on continued
exponential cost declines in
computational power in storage density
Moore's law drives electronics
communications and computers and has
become a primary driver in drug
discovery biotech bioinformatics medical
imaging and Diagnostics as Moore's law
crosses critical thresholds a former lab
science of trial and error
experimentation becomes a simulation
science and the pace of progress
accelerates dramatically right becoming
an information business and creating
opportunities for new entrants and new
industries as weii as a venture
capitalist I love it basically think of
an example Boeing building aircraft they
used to rely on wind tunnels to test
novel aircraft design performance ever
since CFD modeling became powerful
enough to simulate this design moves to
the rapid pace of iterative simulations
in the nearby wind tunnels at NASA Ames
and all around the country lie fallow
they aren't used for aircraft design
ever since the Boeing 777 the engineer
can iterate at a rapid rate while simply
sitting at their desk now every industry
in our planet is going to become an
information business I think that's an
important statement every industry
consider agriculture you ask a farmer in
20 years in the future about how they
compete it will depend on how they use
information from satellite imagery
driving robotic field optimization to
the code meaning the programming code in
their seats the genetic code it'll have
nothing to do with Merck Manship or
labor again nothing to do with our
workmanship or labor the historical
basis of competition perhaps in
agriculture or a breeding line right
it'll become eventually information
business and that will eventually
percolate through every industry as
information technology innervates the
economy it makes it have a nervous
system so the interesting thing about
Moore's law nonlinear shifts in a market
place are also essential for
Entrepreneurship and meaningful change
technology's exponential pace of
progress has been the primary juggernaut
a perpetual market disruption spawning
wave after wave of opportunities for new
companies without disruption
entrepreneurs will not exist Moore's law
is not just exogenous to the economy it
is why we have economic growth and an
accelerating pace of progress at future
ventures my venture firm we see this in
the growing diversity and global impact
of the entrepreneurial ideas we see each
year the industry is impacted by the
current wave of tech entrepreneurs are
more diverse and an order of magnitude
larger than those of the 90s today we're
looking everything from automobiles to
aerospace to agriculture and energy so
now one might ask the question as I said
it's almost cosmological why why would
this trend hold for 120 years I mean it
has nothing to do with the semiconductor
industry it has nothing to do what we
were first told by Intel and others that
this was something very unique and
tightly coupled to how we do integrated
circuits why more generally does
progress perpetually accelerate for
Humanity that's a really important thing
by the way that wasn't obvious to people
back in the pre-agricultural period when
bearded prophets could only forecast
doom or the occasional flood or natural
disaster wiping out humanity that was
the perception of the world basically
struggle through occasionally get wiped
out by calamity we now can understand
and hopefully those in technology fully
understand that we are in a pace
perpetual progress we keep getting
better
culturally evolutionarily in the way
that we live our lives in our overall
happiness in the amount of human
suffering in our circle of empathy we
just keep making progress how could that
be why is that well here's one simple
possible explanation coming again back
to Moore's law as one canonical example
why does this 120 year version of
Moore's law perpetuate well consider
that all new technologies are a
combination of technologies that already
exist it's a recombination of prior
ideas innovation does not occur in a
vacuum it is a combination ideas from
before like standing on the shoulders of
giants in any academic field the
advances today are built on a large
edifice of history this is why major
innovations tend to be ripe and tend to
be discovered in the at nearly the same
time by multiple people think about
Edison Tesla Marconi in history all
discovering massive major new
innovations within months of each other
the compounding of ideas is the
foundation of progress something that
was not so evident to the casual
observer before the age of science
science tuned the process parameters for
innovation it basically became the best
method for a culture to learn in the
scientific method I would still assert
has been the greatest advance in human
history on how we accumulate knowledge
and how we make progress over time
versus personal beliefs you know you
name it right it's just saying I think
something's the case and having that be
as valid as any other person's thoughts
so from this conceptual basis come the
origin of economic growth and
accelerating technological change think
of it as the common
toriel explosion of possible idea
pairings which it grows exponentially as
new ideas come in the mix it basically
grows in the order of two to the nth
power of possible sub groupings by
something called reads law REE D if you
don't look it up on Wikipedia
they say explains the innovative power
of urbanization and networked
globalization it explains why
interdisciplinary ideas are so much more
powerfully disruptive than those that
just come from the warmth of the herd
it's like the differential immunity of
Epidemiology where islands of cognitive
isolation think of academic disciplines
with their own boundaries and vernacular
are vulnerable to destructive memes
hopping across much like the South
America was the smallpox from Cortez in
the conquistadors if disruption is what
you seek
cognitive island hopping is good place
to start mining the interstices between
academic disciplines and it is this
combinatorial explosion of possible
innovation pairings that creates
economic growth and it's about to go
into overdrive in recent years we've
begun to see the global innovation
effects of a new factor the internet
people can exchange ideas like never
before long ago people were not
communicating across continents
frequently ideas were partitioned and so
the success of nations and regions
pivoted on their own innovations Richard
Dawkins states that in biology it is
genes that really matter and we as
people are just vessels for the
conveyance of genes it's the same idea
with memes memes meaning ideas we are
the vessels that hold and communicate
ideas and now a pool of ideas percolates
on a global basis more rapidly than ever
before so I think we're gonna be
entering a period of innovation like
never before and in the next four to
five years three billion new minds will
come online for the first time to join
this global conversation via inexpensive
smart phones connecting in the
developing world to satellite links from
StarLink this new product from SpaceX
and perhaps others these people are not
currently coupled to the global economy
in any meaningful way other than
Unilever or Procter & Gamble they are
just out there doing subsistence farming
and not communicating and not
contributing the ideas that they might
be able to contribute to the global
conversation this rapid influx of 3
billion people to the global economy is
unprecedented in human history and so
too will be the pace of idea pairings in
progress we live in interesting times at
cusp of the frontiers of the unknown and
breathtaking advances but it should
always feel that way
engendering a perpetual sense of the
future shock hey guys this is Tim again
just a few more things before you take
off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me would you enjoy getting a short
email for me every Friday event provides
a little morsel of fun before the
weekend and 500 Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favourite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favourite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoy
[Applause]